nous avons obtenu des échanges de
courriels de 2019 et 2020 dans lesquels
on apprend qu'il travaille sur un projet
de site de stockage de déchets hautement
radioactifs au canada le professeur de
géologie de l'université d'ottawa yann
club nous explique de quoi il s'agit
c'est vraiment comme une mine avec un
puits en profondeur et des galeries qui
sort do en profondeur pour avoir des
espaces vraiment poster que déchets
nucléaires une lettre d'un ancien
premier ministre canadien destiné aux
potentiels partenaires japonais révèle
où pourrait se situer le site de
stockage
le green it ce que du labrador serait
parfait pour cette utilisation
la finlande a déjà un site de ce genre
et le canada aussi un projet en marche
en ontario dont on discute publiquement
depuis des décennies pour stocker les
déchets des centrales nucléaires
canadiennes
mais le projet discuté dans les
courriels est complètement différent et
secret d'ailleurs l'un des hommes
d'affaires du japon écrit à l'ancien
premier ministre canadien le plus grand
soin est nécessaire pour que cette
information ne soit pas divulguée ah si
ça se faisait ça serait sensationnel
parce que ça ne s'est jamais fait et il
ya de bonnes raisons pourquoi ça s'est
pas fait
michael snyder est un consultant
international en énergie nucléaire basé
à paris nous lui avons fait lire les
courriels que nous avons tenu la
première réaction a été une stupéfaction
à quel point des gens extrêmement haut
placés se rassemblent dans une espèce de
conspiration incroyable une conspiration
clairement destiné à garder au secret un
plan est de le faire avancer
suffisamment loin pour confronter les
décideurs avec des faits accomplis